we'd have to put our planet in orbit
about 1 and A2 trillion kilm away from
UI scoote at this distance it would take
about 10,000 years for Earth to complete
just one orbit around the celestial
body that would change our entire
concept of Life as we know it each
season would last 2500 years that means
that entire civilizations could rise and
fall without ever seeing more than one
season for most people summer might be
something they've only heard about
through
Legends in case a Perpetual winter isn't
bad
enough don't forget that the orbit
around uy scooty would be located right
in the middle of the Milky Way where
cosmic rays and light from other stars
would shine bright enough to keep our
sky blue all day and night